the only other the other factor is
psychotropic drugs yep and these are two
things that no one wants to talk about
correct and they're both real and
they're both facts and why is it that
you think that these are there they're
obvious facts that people want to ignore
because you they don't actually want to
fix the problem right if you fix the
problem then you don't have controversy
if you know of controversy you don't
have a left versus right paradigm do you
guys that's what it is yes then first up
they don't want to touch the car did
they don't want to fix the problem if
you want to fix the problem of school
shootings right there's two things
remember as I'm as you've heard me say
before the school shooting while it is a
murder at its core it's actually a
public suicide and people to understand
that at its core most mass shootings are
public suicides they would understand
that shows like death by cop right it's
public suicide so you have to make sure
you have happier people right but then
one at a school why do they choose
schools several reasons one because
that's where they're they're assumed
enemies are right the in cells think
that the guys the bad guys and the bad
girls were there but something else
there's soft targets the other thing you
remember from all these school shootings
is they're planned and that's a critical
aspect you want to stop school shooting
in New York State you don't have to pass
one extra law at all have do one minor
thing and one thing only and that is say
if you are a licensed if you're licensed
and you have a permit to carry a firearm
if you want to in school you may if
you're a teacher or administrator if you
want to you may that's it
you'd have to force a teacher to carry
you don't need a resource officer why
because if you have a resource officer
which is what most Republicans will say
put an officer there they'll just shoot
him first if you're all Democrats no
guns they'll shoot everybody so if you
instead say well I don't know who's
armed is it an administrator as a
teacher is everybody is it nobody the
planning goes away once there's no
planning available the school is no
longer a soft target
they stopped choosing the school okay
let me back let son practice so you're
saying that if you have an officer on
the school that carries a gun and this
person knows that officer has a gun they
will shoot him first correct and that if
just teachers are carrying guns there's
no way this person knows and so they're
less likely to shoot people unless
there's two things if you here's a core
of it
what's killing our children it's not
firearms the the one of the I think was
a Texas shooting I think it was before
he stole the guns he had put together
and set up pipe bombs and pressure
cooker bombs in case he couldn't steal
the guns so if he couldn't get guns he
was going to kill people anyway the key
thing here is what's killing P's kids
lack of community lack of purpose and
loneliness that's what's killing our
kids those three things take those three
things away kids don't do that you give
a kid who's 16 17 18 purpose he can't go
off and kill people who has something to
do here's a reason to live remember this
is a public suicide if you have a reason
to live and you think the right answer
is to go do something you don't kill
yourself if you don't kill yourself
there's no public suicide mass shootings
all of a sudden are tremendously reduced
it's just how it works it's human nature
you have to understand that but if you
do that then there's no extra law then
there's no one to point a finger at you
can't restrict guns I'm saying this
makes actual sense this is where you and
I great company because I don't agree
with that I don't think that anyone is
trying to keep these school shootings in
the same state there are now I think
that there's two things one no one wants
to demonize psychotropic drugs
especially politicians they have a
really hard time with that sure because
they don't want to tell people who are
on psychotropic drugs that there are
either suspects or suspicious or
potential mass shootings it's incorrect
I'm we made this a fact and thus a fact
literally says if you go on these drugs
you lose your firearm so that's
absolutely not true New York State it
may be true in California I don't know
your laws here but in New York State the
opposite is true we've we've already
done that we have made our medical
personnel part of our secret State
Police which means if you go in and say
you know I'm feeling depressed I need
some drugs I'm thinking about suicide
the state police might come by and take
your firearms that's already happening
in New York State and they now want to
create red flag laws which means a
teacher can now do it so now a teacher
says oh there's a student who I see drew
a firearm he drew a gun cops and robbers
may be a red flag let me go to a judge
and see if I can have the cops go and
take his father's fire I definitely want
to talk about this but I want to bring
it back to what you said earlier you
don't think they want to fix the problem
yet you know
think that's true I just don't think
they have a viable solution that they
think is politically viable perhaps but
I think my solution seems cloaca viable
people I say everyone I say this too
they go oh wow you're right well you are
definitely right that they're lonely sad
people that are lashing out I think
you're definitely right that in many
instances it's a public suicide yep and
I think you're definitely right that the
vast majority of them are on
psychotropic drugs yeah which do have a
disassociative aspect to them where
they're not even sure they're aware of
what they're doing this is those well
people that have been on these things
things don't mean anything and like a
car accident in front of them doesn't
mean anything people have various
reactions to various SSRIs and
antidepressants but one thing that
happens is you lose the highs and lows
and everything is just flat you become
numb yes and you become numb to almost
anything it happens absolutely again it
varies depending upon the individual
that's on these things sure part of that
would allow someone to do something
horrific which they wouldn't be able to
before well there's two things for
memory are one I'm not concerned with
being righteous I'm concerned with happy
New Yorkers and happy people that's what
I want righteousness is very low on my
priority of things so if that doesn't
sound if what I'm saying sounds bad I'm
okay I want to fix the problem the
second thing is another politician which
means I don't have I don't have a career
I have to protect I don't have interests
I have to serve the average donor is $75
so I don't have a bunch of people who
are I mean huge checks so don't have
that concern either so maybe in four
years I'll be corrupted and you can beat
no I don't think you're corrupt I mean
I'm not saying that at all well I mean
they're corrupt I mean I'm sure many of
them are sure but I think that they just
there's things they don't feel like they
can discuss politically and I think one
of those things is in any way demonizing
people are on antidepressants because a
lot of these along in percentage of
people absolutely our our opioid crisis
is is heavily based upon the idea that
when you have pain of any type physical
mental the answer is
not dealing with that pain but the
answer is a once-a-day pill right
meditation yes that is the answer for
all of our pain and because of that you
have a lot of people who are on drugs
and you partner a stat about 80% of all
the people who are currently heroin
addicts somehow started on some ones
that even know is theirs but someone's
prescription legal legal drug I mean
that was prescribed for the pain
medication or something like that
usually pain medication yeah but other
things too you're totally correct this
is a problem but what I'm saying is this
what I talk about often people say Larry
you know why should I vote for you why
should I support you
here's reason why whether you believe I
can win or not it's actually irrelevant
if you think I can win awesome I can win
and to be forward with you if I win in
New York as a libertarian the entire
nation changes overnight and that's not
exaggeration the entire nation changes
overnight this is the most impactful
election hands-down the entire nation
twenty